i'm a little tired of all this uh
terrorist
uh alarming and the terrorist hatred all
this
anti-terrorist you know terrorists are
just people
who like to murder other people what the
[ __ ] is the big problem
seriously i think that they're they
become victimized in this country
because they have they it's those are
their religious beliefs and they have a
right to them
to murder people because here's the
thing what do they do that's so bad they
kill people
who the [ __ ] who were so what
what's so great about people
that they shouldn't be allowed to murder
them like i was really thinking about
that like
so people die yeah
[ __ ] i don't know them so i don't i
honestly don't care
and if somebody well what if somebody
you knew died
well that would be sad but then there's
the other side to it which is i get to
act
sad and people would be worried about me
and really concerned about me
you know like when you were in school
did you ever have when you were in
school when you were a kid like
fantasies about your parents dying so
that you'd be really special in school
like if your parents got killed you'd go
to school and they'd make an
announcement
joey's parents died today so everybody
and all the cute girls would come up and
go are you okay
and stuff like that which would never
happen they just woke up you go i'm
still not gonna [ __ ] you you
[ __ ]
that's what would have happened and that
would have even i would have jerked off
to that and had a better time than if i
[ __ ] them
seriously to me jerking off later
cute girl saying that to me after my
parents died like the brutalness of that
would have gotten me off better than
[ __ ] that stupid [ __ ]
i don't need her i have no idea
no idea where this is going i like girls
man i like all kinds of girls big
small sleeping
dated a lazy eye girl for a little bit
hell of a skeet shooter
i used to get mad and get up in her face
and go pull and watch her eye go off
like that
and she was always saying she saw ufos
i'm like every other light you see
slowly moves off in the distance
now quit reporting our lamps
i like a tough girl man i like a strong
girl you know what i'm saying
kind of girl that gets into some things
kind of girl maybe a little diesel on
her breath maybe some stains in her
mouth
kind of girl that ain't ain't afraid to
just snatch a goat off a bridge
kind of guy that ain't afraid to start
some [ __ ] at a funeral who's dead [ __ ]
a tough girl man because you know if you
got a tough woman you know if times get
tough
she'll breastfeed everybody
even the cats
a healthy woman can cook they'll provide
for you they take care of you
skinny women a lot of women don't go
[ __ ] nobody cooks anymore
and all you ladies should be cooking
because the lord wants you to
i'm serious he told me that in a dream
but here's my thoughts ladies if god
didn't want you to cook at the good lord
didn't want you to cook then why didn't
he naturally put
milk and eggs in your body
ingredients mama
now why don't you do the lord's work and
hook us up with some french toast
he's hungry
while we're talking about charitable
stuff as you leave this evening there's
going to be a bucket collection there's
people with buckets and tins and i'll
just briefly tell you what it's about
we're collecting money this evening for
abused children
and if we raise between us just 500
pounds we can buy
their silence
so a fly landed on my shoulder like a
[ __ ] falcon
i feel like a solid
bro do you see this fly flying into me
this goddamn isis mosquito
that's my level of pale isn't that crazy
like there are lights that the fly
should fly into
i'm so pale the fly thinks i'm the
source of life
is it really
why
[Music]
i hate how much fun black people can
have racially man it's just
i can say anything i goddamn want
racially and why people have to sit
there and take it no
oh yeah i'm evil yes he's like come on
man
i i don't even say it because of that i
like i love i i love a little ratio yes
look man you know let's be fair i mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game i
mean
i like to talk to uh you know white
people about being honest about uh
obama you gave it a shot you did
you gave it a two year shot like oh yeah
i tried i tried to
we tried to but you see not
it's not it's just it fell apart it
really
it really did and i'm gonna tell you
something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side uh
and talking to white people we would be
on your side a lot more if you would uh
you know just not ever talk about
how you feel about anything
racial we'll catch up to you not serious
cause black people are on the edge of
going what the [ __ ] is obama doing
but it's too many white people outwardly
hating them so we can we go if you shut
the [ __ ]
you shut up i'll be against them like
stop i'm loving rallies and all kinds of
stuff i'm telling you i'm this close to
i'm mad at him because i thought i would
have a white slave but i thought
i thought it was vengeance day
gonna have me a white family oh big old
fat white girl go warm up better get
upstairs susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and
i'm gonna go outside and stare your
husband in the face and decide whether
i'm gonna sell them or not
and you know your wife's upstairs
warming up my bed you know that right
phillip
that's uncomfortable in it that's
something that's uncomfortable i
apologize